hey guys so this is the pronouncement
week of Whitestone Boise ah finals have
hit quite hard thing hey guys so this
past week has been the pronouncement
week of revision I've had for my finals
and such I don't have all of that much
to talk to you about what little I can
tell you is that I had a form of bullets
and Peter's worried this this and this
one of the best if not the best formal
vegetarian means I've ever had and my
mate Ryan who does history finished his
exams and we got him in a rather
spectacular thrashing Ryan's a guy who
eats toast a lot like for a lot of his
meals so we got him with a garland of
toast and attacked him with bread before
throwing him in the river before that
we've also got him with champagne and
various substances but what I've been
largely dealing with is preparing for
exams and I don't want to talk anymore
about physics because frankly I'm sick
of talking about physics I have been all
week what I thought I'd talk about is
the structure taking exams in Oxford and
sort of how it works I notice a few
people are asking that question in
comments previously in order to do this
however I need a costume change this is
subtask this is our formal University
where so what we wear for matriculation
graduation University ceremonies and
exams I really quite like wearing self
busk kind of feels like putting on armor
when you get ready for example so I've
mentioned this in another video but to
repeat what I said before there's a
difference between humanity students and
science students when it comes to taking
exams in Oxford the only exams which
count was the humanity students degree
classification are those at the end of
their three years so they can take
anything up to I think the most I've
heard was 28 hours of exam in space of a
couple of weeks and taking those exams
will determine what they get their
degree whether they get a first
- one two - third or not getting a
degree science students such as myself
on the other hand take exams every year
of their degree and they all count
towards your final mark this means that
by the time taking my last two papers
this year I already have 80% or so of my
degree already done for better or for
worse and the structure varies from
subject to subject so for example in
physics in second year everybody will do
the same papers everyone would do I've
got to remember
it was two years ago thermal physics
quantum physics and electromagnetism
optics and everyone knows those papers
in third year there's a difference
between those doing a three of course in
a four year course if you're doing a
three of course you just do four exams
if you're doing a four year course you
take six exams everybody doing the four
year course takes the same papers and
those aren't doing the three oh course
choose four papers from those six then
when it comes to fourth year there are
seven options to choose from and
everybody chooses to so there's a lot
more it spreads out as the degree goes
on for something like history for
example though people choose whatever
modules they want to take pretty much
beyond the start of their degree when
they get the basics laid down they are
free to take whatever modules they want
and then have to revise them all at the
very end this means that no two people
will have exactly the same exam
timetable although there are certain
papers which everyone will take so for
example in history again everybody takes
their last paper together which is kind
of nice because it means that when you
finish you have a site like this now
when you combine taking so many hours of
exams like say 28 or 24 hours of exams
in a space of a couple of weeks with the
pressure of knowing what it means this
is what's going to determine the way the
world sees you and add into that the
fact that you have to dress up fancy for
it you had to go to a special building
that awful lot of tension in Oxford at
this time of you basically I cannot wait
until I get my red carnation actual
products Pamela means so there's a
tradition in Oxford that was only
started a couple of decades ago geez
that puts in perspective that students
who are taking their exams all wear a
carnation a flower on your lapel
I'm not wearing what I don't know ten
fake if you're a student taking your
first exam you are a white carnation if
you are in the middle of your exam
period and you're taking a per se you
take five papers for your first example
where a white carnation then for your
second third and fourth papers you were
a pink carnation and then if your last
paper you were a red carnation when you
see someone who's wearing a red
carnation you know how much they've gone
through you know how much pain is
suffering they've had to enjoy to get to
that point where they're about to finish
and you haven't finished so you hate
them thank you guys for your amazing
response to my shout out video asking
for questions if you don't know what I'm
talking about
I've loaded a video early in the week
and as you can watch it you can find out
yourself also thank you for your
intervention or comments they were
incredible they really actually boost
a lot of it because a bunch of my
friends were looking at the comments
section and found some which were
genuinely motivating them so thank you
very much anyone who has taken exams in
the moment the very best of luck to you
I know your pain believe me I know your
pain and for this week's comment I are
you need to be cheered up so complete
the sentence if I had a million pounds I
would go be creative Jamie enjoy your
lack of exams you lucky yeah and I will
see you guys in a week's time
probably very briefly